que ce matin c'est Clémentine autant
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
député la France insoumise de la
Seine-Saint-Denis on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par Stéphane
Vernet de westfrance bonjour Stéphane
bonjour bonjour
et la question évidemment de début c'est
autour de ces discussions discussion qui
se sont poursuivies hier jusque tard
entre les insoumis les écologistes et
qui reprennent ce matin et qui
reprennent avec les socialistes et les
communistes mais aucun accord n'a été
conclu qu'est-ce qui bloque d'abord
c'est long c'est long de se reparler de
faire le point sur les ambitions
programmatiques et ce que l'on peut
partager c'est ça va pas de soi donc il
faut comprendre qu'on a besoin de ce
temps ce temps d'explication ce temps de
précision et d'essayer d'avoir un accord
de nature politique on l'a dit depuis le
début nous on veut pas une simple
répartition ou une simple vous voyez ce
que je veux dire
c'est vraiment une union politique
puisque l'enjeu c'est de gouverner le
pays à partir du mois de juin donc il
faut savoir sur quelle base on gouverne
et donc quelle proposition politique
nous faisons ensemble on va parler du
fond mais c'est le fond qui bloque c'est
des questions ce sont des questions de
programmatiques ou c'est la répartition
des circonscriptions qui posent problème
ou les deux par définition les deux vous
imaginez bien que on travaille en
parallèle sur la répartition des
circonscriptions et c'est pas simple je
vais pas vous cacher les choses
évidemment ça n'est pas simple donc ça
suppose beaucoup d'aller retour beaucoup
de discussions de d'argumentation et de
voilà j'espère qu'aujourd'hui puisque
nous sommes le 3 mai anniversaire du
Front populaire nous réussirons à
l'issue de cette journée d'avoir un
grand un grand accord qui permettent je
crois de nous hisser à la hauteur de
l'histoire et des de l'urgence sociale
et écologique que rencontrent la France
aujourd'hui ce temps d'explication une
précision que vous évoquez vous vous
n'avez pas eu avant la présidentielle
vous avez négocié pendant des mois
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui change non
vous n'êtes pas parler du tout
finalement en vrai non on peut pas dire
qu'on ne se soit beaucoup parlé
en revanche c'était impossible de le
faire avant la présidentielle pourquoi
c'est possible maintenant permettez-moi
juste de revenir sur ce que vous
soulignez pendant la présidentielle ce
sont même des noms d'oiseaux assez
désagréables que nous avons entendu
notamment à l'encontre de Jean-Louis
discussion 0 échange organique
était était sympathique et chaleureuse
[Musique]